Talia for wins in the last four games
you're really making a run for it how do
you feel right now I feel great um
but we have the weather yesterday and it
looked
it looked momentum I'm quite happy with
the game from today so hopefully just
goes well for me until the end of the
tournament were you concerned about
losing the momentum uh due to the rest
day or I was a little bit but I was more
busy either trying to catch up with
school work or trying to meet some
friends so I think maybe it was nice
that I did get distracted absolutely
take us through the game because it felt
like quite a smoother game by you right
did you get the preparation that you
wanted over just oh exactly maybe you
can
um deduce that based on the amount of
time I spent in the evening but I was
pleased with the position that I had
um I wasn't exactly sure which plan I
was going to go for and actually it
seemed it felt like the position changed
a couple of times
because for example here I was down to
play with like F4 with D4 yeah with D3
and I D2 and Knight F3 something like
that maybe even G4 at some point but
then the the I guess the position just
kept on changing
um and then she played this bishop C5
which obviously forces me to play with
D4
um but I was I was all right with the
position that we got and I think uh
maybe a few moves later
um
right so here I felt like things started
to look up for me I wasn't exactly sure
how to evaluate the position before that
but obviously she can take on C5 with
the Knight because then there is before
um and I thought it was just a strange
decision by her to go to KCA but now
it's not so clear right because my Pawn
on A2 is hanging right so Queen takes A2
I was considering Bishop C3 or Bishop D4
I kind of liked Bishop D4 catch this
this in somehow right right but it keeps
on escaping like after rookie won the
queen season two and it keeps on
escaping so I thought maybe bishop D4
was more accurate since it's more
um direct and maybe I was concerned
Bishop D4 something like Rook C7
um at first I was looking at Rook F2 but
I think uh she didn't just played Queen
C2 and I don't have any nice night night
jump
um so no 94 because you can take it
right or the pot yeah so probably
instead of Rook of two I had to do
something else
taking over the initiative in the game
um
I felt like when I got a3b4 in my
position was beginning to get good and
um yeah so after E4 the issue that her
pieces are very misplaced and I was very
surprised
um honestly I think I missed maybe Queen
F5 also works here I'm not sure
um instead of five years
yeah it looks fine but after a rookie
Aid
um yeah I here I thought that I was
doing pretty well and I was quite
surprised when she went for Queen C4
because she did think about this move
quite a bit but
after a night of five I don't think
there is there is much hope and
especially after he took on D5 and
allowed Knight to E3 I was quite
surprised because she was thinking and
then she also went for this line so I
thought okay maybe I missed something
but there's nothing and I think after
that it's just
um a nice conversion
absolutely no problems Talia
congratulations four out of four uh
tomorrow you're facing begin you know
her quite well you've played her quite a
few times and you guys are friends as
well how is that the Rivalry going on
um we have played two times she actually
has a plus score against me last year's
championship I got lucky and made a draw
with black hopefully this time I can
just get a better game than last time
absolutely guys any questions for us
yeah absolutely first of all tell you
congratulations very very nice four in a
row I just uh just a moment of honesty
between us only uh five days ago did you
wake up and say wouldn't it be nice to
win four games in a row was that on your
mind at all did you say yeah okay now
turn on the heat
there wasn't a specific moment where I
thought that I was going to start
winning games but I had some trust that
I was gonna that it was gonna happen at
some point
um even though I lost to Irina it was a
very bad game I kind of felt like
overall my play was fine and that wins
were gonna show and I just left it in
the air with trust and actually you have
now seven points at the moment and not a
clear third place maybe even better who
knows by the end of this round what are
your Ambitions in this event right now
especially considering this tournament
situation
well going to the tournament
um I mentioned I wanted to go top three
and I'm happy that I'm on track
um obviously it's very difficult I
believe before this round we're maybe
six tied for the top three spots so it's
obviously still very complex and I I'm
not sure what's gonna happen I don't
want to think about it too hard either
I'm just gonna try and focus on my game
um tomorrow and the day after but
certainly it would be amazing if I can
get top three yeah Talia congratulations
absolutely penultimate round coming up
tomorrow and then the championship round
as well uh Jennifer again she's uh